[Musique]
non ça va je suis je sors de chez le
vétérinaire
qu'est ce qu'il ya tu malade comme un
chien c'est pas plus et j'ai une fièvre
de former qu'une dispute arrive que
j'entends pas bien du tout mais non ça
va s'arranger quand même tout préparé le
ja oui je vois que tu as préparé des tas
de choses
il ya énormément d'objets sur cette
établi j'adore et qu'est ce que nous
allons faire
bombay alors qu'est ce que tu veux dire
que j'ai pas fait de mineurs et sitafa
images et les mots doivent commencer à
laisser là ça va s'arranger
il dit quand même bon soir à toulouse ce
soir bonsoir
alors ce jeu alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
que je sois alors il ya deux bocaux de
faranah temps sur mes enfants deux bons
coups dans un jet de la grenadine bon
ces deux là tu veux oui et dans l'autre
c'est vide
bah oui je vois alors le principe oui le
liquide doit passer dans le bocal vide
oui voilà c'est ce qu'il faut que je
fasse c'est ce qu'il faut que tu fasses
pas demain sinon non sans y toucher
ah bon tu choisis touchés comme ça voilà
comment ça vous classe ans oui je me
sers de ça pour être pauvre tête sans
cervelle bien sûr enfin un coup c'est un
c'est un simple tuyau
oui c'est un tuyau de caoutchouc avec il
est vide j'espère car il sait pas
tellement difficile à c'est que c'est
pas tellement dépassé le elle va se
faire tuer le faire tu vas voir le
principe du cifor je vais siphonner
tiens regarde je mets ça là dedans
maintenant j'aspire oui jusqu'à ce que
le liquide arrive au bout du tuyau de le
coincer je leur mets là dedans moi là
bas tu vas voir attention pas trop c'est
bon maintenant va c'est maladroit
c'est effrayant défaut saurait le faire
ça ne lui a pas fait un poc recommence
faut pas s'énerver sympa comme sale
états unis en riant t le suis malade
comme une peau hâlée à tous
là maintenant tu vois que tu y arrives
tu parles d'un gentil alors en principe
ça vient c'est pas enfin je vais trouver
un jeu qui ne peut pas faire j'ai jamais
tarie c'est malin mais je ne la vois pas
j'ai bien que j'ai trouvé ça m'a guéri
mais voilà que chacun on a fait des
choses j'ai jamais tandis abbaoui assez
malin c'est malin je vais te dire je
sais pourquoi ça marche pas et pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que ça
n'est pas comme ça qu'il faut préparer
l'opération et leur faire eh ben je vais
te montrer
il faut que le bocal soit plus haut oui
voilà je vais le raeo c'est comme ça et
que l'autre soit beaucoup plus bas et à
ce moment-là ça à mort ceux ci font tu
comprends aux iphone tu m'as laissé le
ridiculiser devant toulon je te remercie
maintenant ça ce matin ça marche alors
je fais manche 1
bon et maintenant ça démarre vous voyez
puisque bien l'autre bocal était en
dessous ça démarre et maintenant nous
allons avoir le principe des vases
communicants c'est à dire que le niveau
devrait s'établir exactement à la même
hauteur des deux côtés ce qui est en
train d'ailleurs de se produire et elle
est vraiment produire d'ailleurs
automatiquement automatiquement les
mêmes puis à peine de s'en occuper ou
verrez ça va marcher tout seul
voilà comment il fallait faire enfin
bouger ça redonne il a voulu me voir il
a failli m'avoir redisons l'uimm a eu
plein jeu comme ça en a beaucoup
oui oui tu vas voir alors qu'est ce que
je fais maintenant l'attention du fait
des vagues
je fais des vins croyable ça y est on
est au niveau 1 et au niveau des deux
côtés bon alors on passe à autre chose
on passa au-dessus engagement b alors
alors fans ont chacun payé tous les deux
oui mais trois tous les quatre ans où
est ce que vous vous en regardez on va
te préparer quelque chose d'un service
il n'est pas méchant
moi je vais me diffamer je l'aimais
traîner poussé par le vent a oui très
bien oui j'ai eu ce que tu fais
attention je crois qu'il pleut un aaa
bien d'autres il alors à la belle oui si
oui on est là le point commun le bleu
pas comme si vous l'avez vous savez de
vous savez de quoi il s'agit mais on
appelle fabrice je vous la cherchez
c'est la fin d'un fabrice o appris via
voyais pas venir
pas trop difficile on ne peut pas être
difficile que ce que tu viennes alors tu
sais ce que c'est le point commun
l'image est peut-être le rappeler à nos
amis tout même le système du point
commun consiste à écouter attentivement
tout cancan belles belles et pousse
moussu et à trouver le point commun qui
existe entre les trois choses qu'ils
doivent personnifiée alors toi tout cas
encore aujourd'hui tu es quoi est bien
loin aujourd'hui je suis une fourchette
mais dire que je vis généralement à côté
d'une assiette dans laquelle il ya des
tas de bonnes choses des gâteaux d'une
cuisse de poulet des macaronis et la
sauce en fait wayne tout ce qui se mange
les qui est très bon mais c'est grâce à
moi que vous pouvez piqué toutes ces
bonnes choses dans votre assiette et les
manger bon je sais je sais bien que dans
certains cas on se pense de moi pour
manger des pommes de terre frites par
exemple mais il faut avouer qu'on a eu
bien raison de m'inventer car je suis
vraiment très pratique
oui mais moi aussi je suis très pratique
car je suis une si je n'ai pas la
prétention d'être une de ces énormes si
avec lesquelles ont si les arbres non je
ne suis qu'une faible femme
je le comparerais plutôt à une de ces
petites aussi à découper qui permettent
de fabriquer des petits objets des
boîtes des coffrets du cadre mais méfiez
vous tout de même deux mois il faut me
manipuler avec précaution
sinon je m'en allais terrible à mon père
je suis allez ça va être à toi poussa
oui ça va être vrai
alors ben moi moi je suis un crocodile
je vis sur les rivages des grands flops
d'afrique
j'ai parlé à mes shows jeu je pense la
plupart de mon temps à dormir
waouh à faire semblant attention parce
que si un poisson vient se promener près
de moi alors là j'ouvre ma mâchoire qui
est énorme
il claque je le coupe en deux et j'avale
je dois reconnaître aussi que
quelquefois je j'ai attrapé la jambe
d'un nageur un peu imprudent et emma
fois c'était pas beau mais voilà est-ce
que vous même vous avez découvert de
quoi il s'agit alors pouces mossu et
nous a dit que tu étais un crocodile riz
a connu sa mort
wasquehal qu'est ce que tu as là dedans
bon et alors toi bell bell une si si si
et toi tu ou concombre fourchette c'est
ça que j'ai dit est ce que tu as dit
alors et vous pensiez nous coller nos
petits camarades et moi même avec ça
alors que nous sommes très forts dans ce
jeu du point commun vous avez tous
deviné bien entendu de quoi il s'agit
c'est est facile un crocodile une scie
et et quoi je suis un peu moche est une
fourchette tudor un bon ça en commun des
dents voilà pourquoi j'envoie
on s'était passé comme elle voulait nous
avoir la prochaine fois vous en ce sens
beaucoup plus difficile un bon sinon on
passera la suite à mes basset belge elle
qui doit sans alors oui belle panique et
bien là tout était petit bisou à la bon
alors c'est bon c'est mon jeu la main
c'est toi pour ce musée à moi bon alors
qu'elle était prêt fabricant suprême est
prête à temps de tes crayons j'ai appris
j'ai mon crayon alors je vais je veux tu
vas au tableau tu vas le tableau
directement bon alors cette phase et
c'est un mot en onze lettres 11 l'es11
l'être humain pour faire de bêtises non
non non non pas que je commence par tu
commence par un c alors c'est ses onze
lettres onze lettres alors tu fais un de
3,5 résiste 7 8 9 9 et je termine par un
thé 21t voilà aulas a pris 1 il faut que
je devine ce que c'est bien entendu de
vie dont je doute comme d'habitude est
ce que c'est un animal non non c'est pas
un animal est ce que c'est une fleur
ah non non c'est pas une fleur d'une
fait pas une fleur c'est pas un animal
est ce que c'est une plante
non non c'est pas une plante grasse pour
une plante assez pour une plante est ce
que c'est un arbre non non non plus
n'ont fait pana veux tu que je t'aide
est ce que je peux te donner une lettre
la lecture allez la lettre du milieu
aller où là bas la cinquième cas oui et
la cinquième c'est la cinquième c'est un
p 1 p un peu un deux trois quatre cinq
voilà un pays voilà là alors là
maintenant tu devrais trouver là as-tu
des mouvements alors c'était ce que je
peux dire est que je me dire une
indication il y en a beaucoup autour de
moi dans la forêt dans la forêt y en a
beaucoup
rien n'a beaucoup sous les feuilles
l'avocat est ce que ce serait pas lors
du week-end en nombre nous non du couac
il a dit tu dickens du lichen annoncé
près de casser c'est parce qu'avec lui
je me méfie tu t'es dit n'importe quoi
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
vert n'ont cependant guère
est ce que ces blancs des fois des
foyers pas blanc oui ça peut être blanc
oui oui c'est pas un animal non non
c'est pas un animal je sais ce que ça se
mange ah oui ça se voit que ça
recommence à seulement est ce que j'aime
ça moi ah ouais tu devrais mais ça
résume sahraouis cen sad comtois oui oui
moi j'en mange quelques pages en picore
est-ce que c'est rond oui oui la tête et
ronde en tout cas la tête et rojas mange
je verrais bien quelque chose me dit
toujours à l'avant avec ce que tu m'as
donné comme indication sera prête sa
voix je penserai alors là avec la téte
ronde et sa jument je penserai à
champignons et ben voila tu as trouvé
comment l'ignorer bien c'est bien la
toile tout de suite mais sans manquer
fils à champignons voyons comment tu
écris champignons pas que ce soit comme
ça se prononce comme ça se prononce ah
oui mais enfin tu mets un thé à la fin
de champignons bah oui mais c'est
insensé
un champignon des cats et c'est
incroyable ah non ça ne s'écrit pas
comme ça du tout chantier un crêpage
vous prie de bien vouloir excuser
pousse-pousse absolument nulle alors
champignons voilà je sais h à m
d'accord et p é g l au t elle
non s ah ouais les champignons crache
encore faim
ça veut dire j'ai trouvé ça avec intérêt
je n'essaie pas de progrès je suis pas
content j'espère au moins que tu
pourrais nous indiquer à weeds et je
sais pas moi des choses importe
eh ben je vous dire justement
ajustements je vais vous dire quelque
chose d'important quoi se tromper sur
l'orthographe de champignons ses pensées
contre aggravant bien dormir bien mais
enfin c'est pas très grave
ce qu'il faut surtout surtout ne pas se
tromper sur les champignons
parce qu'il ya les comestibles et puis
les champignons vénéneux 1
et pour ça je vais vous donner un petit
conseil ne vous fiez pas à leur couleur
y en a de très jolis qu'ils sont mortels
ne fuit pas là à leur forme ni à leurs
parfums demander l'avis du paysan de la
région oui mais n'inquiétait pas il les
connaît bien lui ou alors tenez demandez
l'avis de votre pharmacien
c'est encore plus prudent est arrivé des
choses dramatiques les champignons mais
où et touchez pas aux champignons tout
seul sans avoir la vie de quelqu'un qui
connaît bien les champignons et
croyez-moi on peut se tromper alors là
c'est une catastrophe ait des accidents
mortels fait très attention très très
attention c'est ton avis tout cas encore
que tu te serves as tu exactement s'est
passé ton pote vos conseils tu dis moi
tu crois qu'elle est prête d'une belle
maintenant je pense que oui oui d'après
d'ailleurs après le champignon poids qui
ne le change aux jolies demoiselles tout
quand il est à lui écoutons là bas
e
ça ne s'explique
[Musique]
moi je suis content
m
à la tête
wade champagne 2007 est juste plus jours
[Musique]
moi avec moi doris au dos tu veux te
lance maintenant j dont tu m'as l'air
d'un exalté aujourd'hui et des figures
telles que je suis allé en allemagne
excès de travail j'étais à bout il me
fallait absolument prendre un bol d'air
respirer le vent du large
j'ai fait un séjour très agréable du
côté de kiel on ne fréquente pas et
c'est les plages de la baltique loup y
cite douce presque tiennent de la mer si
oui j'ai pris le goût de la vallée se
chargea les à la brasserie du grand
hôtel j'ai vu des attractions
spécifiquement en germanie tout à fait
remarquable il y avait un charmeur de
serpents des groupes folkloriques tout
le monde choc et en buvant de la bière
veut pas prendre une petite pastille
pour éclaircir la voie non plus pas de
petits bonbons des petits bonbons mais
un mythe vergnaud donne donc c'est une
simple formule de politesse je les ai
apprises au cours de la fondation de la
cinquième leçon si tu préfères tu
prenais des leçons d'allemand et chaque
matin avec une jeune fille charmante
bien troupe voir clair
si tu que je parle couramment 21h c'est
quelque chose
j'ai donc le jour où l'autre mon
certificat de poliglote du plan b si
l'on me dise oui
d'ailleurs j'aurais incessamment sous
peu ce certificat
bon je peux expliquer l'idée m'a été
donné par gère trop de bernard que mes
capacités haute émerveillé plus france
ce ne sont pas doués pour les logs c'est
une chose connue
non on ne peut pas les lâcher seul ou
des recoins du monde alors je me propose
c'était les accompagner le dren ni
d'alors anticipe à l'aigle diplômés
l'honneur c'est ce qu'elle fait gertrude
vermeer own et que demi polyglotte est à
moitié du pot mais mon dieu
au bout de trois semaines de leçons gens
savaient plus quelle salle avec ses ânes
on nous sommes restés les meilleurs amis
du monde je peux te le prouver que même
si sa photo gd reçu ce matin regard tu
veux la voir tout et tout va
regarde comme elle est belle regardez en
fallait bien moi oui puisque tu parles
subi en allemand puis ça me donne
nuirait pas j'ai laissé chez moi une
lettre écrit non non mais je trouve que
tu es manque totalement d'observation
mais que tu remarques c'est qu'elle a
dans les masses à cette fête j'ai pas
regardé ce que l'on ait envie que ce
conseil est non comme qu'est ce que tu
as dans les yeux des castagnettes
mais oui version gay oui mon nom de
famille c'est amis enfin je peux dire
c'est oui d'amis jato va aux morts est
sorti de l'académie de castagnettes de
bayreuth avec un premier prix proches va
vous faire
oui oui je fais des castagnettes au site
web et puis tu peux traduire des lettres
des lettres vos fins il faut traduire
celle de fabrice alors je te dis ah non
mais laisse un temps de livrer la
possible non moi je n'ai pas le droit
d'exercer et je n'ai pas encore mon
diplôme
non mais bon ce soir et poète abrisme
oui mais je te prends pas quelqu'un
d'autre
oui ce sera moins bien fait par mois
mais enfin tant pis désolé mais ça avoue
le jeune fabrice beisel a dit plus que
pour alice dautry ce support très calé
en allemand mais tout de même
suffisamment pour avoir quelques doutes
sur son voyage en allemagne moi je sais
pas ça mais qui tend toi tu n'es pas
polyglotte diplômé je suis papou glee
glad peut-être mais enfin je viens des
choses tu m'étonnes valence que la
raconter même la photo bon la photo ça
peut être n'importe qui parfois
franchement des castagnettes en
allemagne l'académie de byron des
castagnettes alors que tout le monde
sait que c'est l'endroit on écoute les
opéras de wagner
on se promet de cette affaire là n'est
pas marqué non plus qu'elle nous a parlé
à un moment de la mer baltique
elle est allée se baigner un article
elle nous a vanté le ciel bleu la
couleur bleue la tiédeur de la mer c'est
une mer du nord de l'europe qui est
prise par les glaces à certains moments
de l'année alors franchement là je doute
couple il est même autre chose qui
m'avait frappé tout con quand qu'est ce
qu'il nous avait dit encore qui était
pas très nets avaient vu des charmeurs
de serpents l'information vient du
charmeur de serpents je crois avec
d'autres groupes folkloriques mais
franchement les charmeurs de serpents en
allemagne on n'a pas pour l'instant eu
droit donc je crois que là encore la
voulu nous bluffer
mais ça ne prendra pas mon faux pas lui
dire parce que vous la connaissez après
les de mauvaise humeur ça sert à rien
ben on refait la vase communicant ah oui
mais voilà je voudrais voir on a du
temps devant nous oui mais il faut se
remettre tout de même dans les
conditions qui étaient les conditions de
départ de l'expérience alors jean lève
donc le tuyau qui sert à siphonner tu
verses et je verse le tout dans un seul
bocal dans un seul mot qu al raya tu as
déjà même à fabrice crime tu sais là
j'ai étudié de très près la question
maintenant que fais je plonge le tuyau
dans
le bocal plein de liquide puis
habilement je prends l'autre bocal de la
main et je le mets à un niveau inférieur
sinon si on recommencera les erreurs de
tout à l'heure ça ne marchera pas pouces
moussu il fasse ifo n'y ait pas son jeu
préféré
voilà alors là ça a marché tu vois et le
liquide va arriver à la même hauteur que
le liquide de l'autre bocal ceux qui le
but de l'opération
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe des
vases communicants pour donc aspirer
dans le tuyau et puis lorsque le liquide
arrive au bout du tuyau
vous le mettez mais à un niveau
inférieur toujours dans l'autre bocal et
ça marche vous voyez les choses alors
atteint le niveau égal des deux côtés
pourrait refaire très exactement la même
chose chez vous l'aurez peut-être
quelques petites difficultés comme moi
mais vous voyez qu'après ça marche très
très bien
je vous souhaite tous très bonne fin
d'après-midi et j'espère que vous allez
réussir sa du premier coup maintenant
vous savez au moins ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire pour commencer on va tous
qu'encore vent pousse aussi les retours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]